let's say we set the variable a to be
equal to five and B is equal to seven
with these variables being set this way
what is going to be the value of a times
B a times B minus three and I'll give
you a few seconds for you to think about
that well everywhere we see an a we need
to replace it with a five and everywhere
we see a B we need to replace it with a
seven so this expression is going to
evaluate to instead of an a we have a
five and so it's going to be five times
B B is 7 so 5 times 7 minus 3 5 times 7
minus 3 order of operations you want to
do your multiplication first 5 times 7
is 35 from that you subtract 335 minus 3
is 32 so this evaluated out to 32 let's
do another one
let's say that the variable X is equal
to negative 1 the variable Y is equal to
2 and let's do another variable in there
let's say the variable Z is equal to 4
and given the way that we've set this X
Y and Z's what would be the value of the
expression x times y x times y plus
let's throw in AZ z times y squared z
times let me write it this way z times y
squared z times y squared and then from
that let's just subtract another X so
and actually let's not be finished here
let's add and then we're gonna add 1 to
the value of what we have already so
plus 1 so what would be the value of
this expression a little bit more
complicated and I think you can figure
it out
what is going to be the value of this
expression this is going to be equal to
what well once again everywhere we see
an X replace it with negative 1
everywhere we see a y replace it with 2
everywhere we see a Z replace it with 4
so this is going to be equal to X is
negative 1 so it's going to be negative
1
x y y is 2 so it's going to be negative
1 times 2 plus plus Z Z is 4 plus 4
times y squared y is 2 so it's going to
be 4 times 2 squared that's the Y
squared right over there and then we
have minus X so we have minus X X is
negative 1 minus negative 1 and then we
have plus 1 plus 1 and now order of
operations you want to do our
multiplication so negative 1 times 2
that's going to be negative 2 and to
that we're going to add we're going to
add well what's 2 squared 2 squared this
right over here is going to be 4 and you
have 4 times 4 I'll do that in this I'll
do that in this green color 4 times 4
that right over there that's 16 and then
over here we have negative or we're
subtracting negative 1 or negative
negative 1
well these negatives cancel out that
just becomes a positive 1 so this part
right over here just becomes a positive
1 and then you're just adding 1 again
right over there so plus 1 and now so
negative 2 plus 16 is positive 14 plus 1
is 15 plus 1 is 16 so this all evaluates
to 16